cracking on the bird yeah and there's
always that one who's got a boyfriend
you have a boyfriend yeah yeah and we do
try our luck yeah of course we try and
graft it we put all the little yeah yeah
everything we can of course and it
always comes down got boyfriend yeah and
then one of the other boys will try they
get the same outcome yeah that's it
that's what I want mother to be like
yeah okay okay okay
you should see my group of friends
we we've got the chat we've got the chat
Auntie if you're gonna say that okay
cool but are you also going to say about
a time when she did have the boyfriend
and you still got through
oh that's that boy listen that's the
girl that's the girl okay wait a minute
you're right wait hold on wait no not
right is that the girl or was that you
no bro that's the girl wait a minute to
go wait a minute to go wait a minute if
you don't believe it's the goal that
means you don't believe no no no no no
no no no no no no I believe the person
because I pass the choice but bro I'm
gonna be honest I'm you know I have I
have trust in my source I believe in my
sauce here but bro if Drake or one of
these guys or the reason why we have to
go no no no no but no but we'll see
again yeah but we're not gonna put us
her and Drake's um scenario listening
yeah yeah well I trust her but I don't
want to feel that type of pain
in it Drake yeah
Drake as examples because no you're all
right you might be Drake to another you
know what I mean yeah
so for someone like you that's obviously
very confident with women a little you
know I mean like like you said 3.5 years
you've been out here doing your thing um
you see a lot of women like you are the
guy that guys worry about because even
with even with a go of a man you are
still dangerous and the problem is
you're over here acting like oh no no
bro guys worry about you like like so
he's not down to the girl though come on
bro no but it's also done to the
environment and guys like you you have
to put some guys are just slick some
guys have got bars some guys have got we
he might have all of these things and
then just that moment with the alcohol
she makes a mistake you see that mistake
yeah yeah that mistake in that one
second yeah where my wife didn't have a
sense ah we could maybe go over
something but that one mistake
Choice China thank you Brit yeah
bro flip it back onto US yeah I don't
care what you say like you could have
the most beautiful women sitting at home
yeah a woman a woman of some women do
know how much power they can have over a
man that they they can be so seductive
and very clever in the way that they act
the way they talk a woman can [ __ ] with
her eyes so I mean if she wants to I
mean so have you ever been [ __ ] with a
woman's eyes
you could put the same scenario on the
other side in the fact that like we us
boys gone a lot of holidays together
we've grown up we go all over the world
together and some of them and lovely
committed relationships and then boys
stay solid and they are they're around
our single boys who are around a lot of
single girls and doing this that and the
other and those boys have to stay solid
yeah they're in them and they do and
we're in them Villas they're winning
scenarios and the boys like boys I'm
going to bed because they and they take
themselves out of that scenario away
from that scene because they've got
beautiful women around them but they
take them can I just say something that
is the first I've heard about
I haven't heard about women taking
himself out the scene
it's the first time I've heard about men
absolutely taking themselves absolutely
um
no but you would find that with me old
school girls go together we leave
together we come back together yeah our
boys our boys are making it sound now is
respectable completely and it just goes
to prove a point there boys will get
women cheat as well as men oh my God
our boys our boys will get cabs home
speaking on behalf of a woman women
cheat as well
I should play innocent women cheat but
who cheats is it modern women or
traditional women modern Auntie no no
I'm going to stop you actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna caveat now
wait a minute let me speak my
grandmother yeah is she the best woman
in the world your grandmother now yeah
yeah she pretty much raised me yeah my
grandmother pretty much raised me since
I was a kid yeah and she's the most
old-school traditional woman in the
world yeah and she's lived a life more
than I could ever imagine and trust me
it doesn't matter what age or what where
you were where you're from that has
happened from women and men since back
in the day but what I'm trying to say is
that I can understand what you're saying
for your grandma's point of view because
there are more women than men so as soon
as someone's got to double up but it's
the way they're doubling up in the old
days
you know you had like old people growing
up then you had people like your
grandmother who had a man out there and
you'd only meet together at funerals and
then realize that you've got all these
cousins and families
I understand absolutely but now the
women the modern women they don't want
to double up unless it's like threesomes
and foursome sometimes that's their way
and
they want to be they're not the
respectable side chick of course I
understand that because in the old days
I knew who you were yeah the man was
married he had another family he can
take care of you and take care of the
family but I find that
the modern women now they just and this
is what I'm saying to Auntie about
earlier about saying listen some girls
you know what level you're on together
yeah she's about that and right we never
judge I don't care I don't care how many
people you slept with I couldn't get I
don't know I've never asked that
question because I don't care because
you shouldn't ask me that question I'm
never going to tell you so you should
because it's none your business okay
yeah I don't care what you've done in
your past history before wait but wait
when you say that well you don't care
because you're not gonna marry them or
not you know what even with Partners I
wouldn't ask that question man so so
okay so if you go ahead I'm different so
if a girl had 50 bodies you wouldn't
mind
no I'm not saying I'm saying you don't
know but if I knew the girl that used
we've had 100 buddies yeah you wouldn't
mind no I'm saying I'm saying so go
having 100 bodies you would you know I
said how can I judge yeah no I'm not
asking you to judge I'm just saying to
you like personally that's what I'm
saying when you sleep with a girl the
way I validate you is what I can't judge
you on stuff you've done in your past
compared to if I've done the same thing
okay okay cool
that's what we're saying earlier men and
women are different you have to get you
you have to
some birds can just literally get it on
a plate I know mate I know if she if she
might have had XYZ history but sometimes
people's lives okay okay cool let me
flip it around let me let your lying in
the bed with your babes one day she said
look babes I love you in it and I just
want to be honest with you I'm just
gonna tell you in it yeah
um
uh uh I made like a video and I got
banged out about 20 man at one time
um wait wait that come on that's wait
hold on a second about me turn around
saying about a gangbang with 30 birds
and it's just me I mean what's the
difference between a hundred sleep over
100 men and sleep over 20 people in one
go yeah in one go on a video that's come
on yeah come on that's well extreme
so there's nothing oh wait a minute
come on because everyone's so stupid all
right okay okay let me check out the
video let me check out the video
she had a 20-man lineup yeah come on no
why because you're getting a come on but
why it's not different take it take this
like Kanye and Kim yeah she made one six
but I'm gonna expose anybody here about
anything like that but you're trying to
tell me you ain't made a sex tape we've
been missing that before of course you
have like but because Ray J exposed that
all of a sudden she's a slag she's not a
snake she made a sex tape with my man
I'm asking a question so so I don't
understand how 100 years 100 bodies
go that's come on
but listen it's not not to a man to me
yeah it's not no difference and let me
tell you something you slept with a
hundred if you slept with 20 men in one
goal or 20 minutes at one time to me
personally you still slept with 20 man
there's no caveat you let 20 minutes but
that's the question but
when you actually meet someone do you
actually ask them about their body count
I've never had anybody else do you
actually um
four years and even when was dating he'd
never even asked me when was he a
pregnant woman
you should ask you now
100 I'm not ashamed of the person I
haven't set up for loads of people no no
but I'm being real like he should if
that was my son
I'm gonna go ask her for you like end of
the day
because because
four years down now you should have been
knowing about yourself
the woman that's about to marry my son
I'm coming to my family actually that's
not appropriate no no hold on hold on a
second actual fact if we take it back to
original wear it for me it is very
appropriate because this is what's the
problem that has happened right
originally what used to happen was all
that happened was I had good promise and
your dad will come and check me the
reason why you women going what is this
wait wait wait hold on listen the reason
you women can't pick men this is why you
always pick the guys that that break
your hearts in that sleep hold on a
second that's why I've got a boyfriend
okay you yeah so let's talk about all
the all the the majority of the women
that have come in this show they keep
moaning about the types of men that they
got but it's the men that you pick
because you keep
types of men you keep men know how to
pick up the [ __ ] from other men the
moment we coming listen every time a guy
meets a mum and someone's mom the mom
loves him oh he's so nice he sold this
but he might have the worst plans for
your daughter but he knows how to
sweeten up the mum the moment the
brother the dad sees him they know while
going straight away us men can pick out
other men's so if you go and bring this
guy to me I can tell whether or not this
guy is going to be a Tyrone or Chad or
Putin
lots of sisters yeah I've got freezers
older or younger
um two older one younger all married all
with a child okay no I'm just asking
because you sound like something that's
really protective
but my Mom this is the thing yeah like
my mum taught us about value like to
understanding it like no one's telling
nobody that you shouldn't have a life
you shouldn't go out there but there's
certain things that people don't do all
this if someone hasn't claimed you if
you don't have a ring on your finger you
are single the only way a man can avoid
not speaking to you Outsiders when I
look at your finger and I know that you
I know that you're married apart from
that everyone's up for game this guy
might be your boyfriend today but you
God willing that you guys go on to get
married but there's no trouble okay cool
but a lot of people think that so unless
he's got a ring on your finger another
man potentially can taste nothing that
means nothing no no no no but in life in
life means nothing happened to anyone
nothing to anyone a ring means nothing
to anyone what about your parents your
mum and dad they're married for 45 years
seven years I would say 47 years extra
two years and you're gonna say that
means nothing it means everything but
what no no no nothing to yourself wait
you second one I said that context
if I see a bird with a ring on her
finger yeah and I'll find her attractive
I'll if I'm still gonna chat to her
women used to wear wedding rings to get
rid of the men and then after a while I
realized that it doesn't work men are
attracted to where they ring so they
like to test the balances
in a place where I know that I'm going
to hit on I put my my this finger I put
it onto my other finger what does it
stop people why no no why would you do
that no because I just think you know
what I want to go out I want to have a
good time but I still respect my man and
I would like to reduce the amount of
people
in the beginning
do you realize right that there is a big
difference in what you're saying because
you're going on like yeah more modern
this and that but when you want to go
out and you be safe you're wearing
something traditional yeah is this
traditional yeah what do you think why'd
you put it on that finger that's for
sure why don't you why don't you put it
on your big toe yeah
because I mean as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible